today's protagonist helped wage war
against the u.s government in defense of
his people's land and if it's war you're
looking to wage that i've got good news
for you because today's video is
sponsored by conflict of nations a free
online strategy game that pits millions
of players against each other worldwide
in conflict of nations you fight up to
64 other players in real time games that
can take weeks to complete the game is
set in the early 21st century and
features modern day weapons and
technology your objective is to take
over the world to find your own strategy
build powerful armies by combining
dozens of different types of infantry
tanks and planes and fight for world
domination in a challenging pvp
environment if real-time modern warfare
sounds like your kind of game you can
join a huge community of millions of
players both in the game and on discord
and use your diplomatic skills to forge
alliances with other players everything
is fully optimized for cross-platform
gaming play with the same account on
both pc and mobile so if this sounds
like your kind of game click the link in
the description below to jump into a
game of conflict of nations and as a
special bonus you guys will receive a
special gift when you sign up using my
link you can snag 13 000 gold a month of
premium subscription for free so click
the link in the description below choose
a country and fight your way to victory
in epic real-time battles
see on the battlefield
to lakota sitting bull was their
greatest leader the one who tried to
guide and protect them during a time of
great and violent turmoil so the
american government sitting bull started
off simply as an annoying obstacle but
became much more than that after handing
them their humiliating defeat at the
battle of a little bighorn afterward he
turned into a dangerous spark one which
they feared could ignite the powder keg
right when they were almost finished
subjugating the native american tribes
to himself sitting ball was a man
looking to preserve the past completely
defiant when it came to his refusal to
abandon the old ways of his people even
if this meant war and even death
[Music]
right off the bat we have a bit of
controversy regarding sitting bull's
birthplace as there's some disagreement
between the official version and the
information passed down through oral
tradition according to the history books
sitting bull was born circa 1831 in
modern-day south dakota on the bank of
the grand river however some of his
descendants assert that the tribal
leader was actually born in montana near
modern-day mars city on the bank of the
yellowstone river sitting bull was part
of the hunk papa lakota tribe themselves
a subdivision of the sioux people his
name in the lakota language was tatanka
leotarko which literally translates as
buffalo bull who sits down but that was
not the name that he had as a child when
he was born he was given the name
jumping badger and later acquired the
nickname slow for his restrained and
calculated demeanor his father and his
uncles were all tribal chiefs there was
a lot of pressure for jumping badger
following their footsteps fortunately
the young lakota seemed determined to
cast off the moniker slow which he
wasn't too fond of and display the four
virtues which were considered
fundamental to the lakota bravery wisdom
fortitude and generosity from an early
age he took part in many games and
competitions that tested his skills and
he showed his mettle when he took down
his first buffalo when he was only 10
years old when he turned 14 years of age
jumping badger was given his first
opportunity to count coup this meant
striking an enemy up close and was the
most common way of gaining war honours
among the native american tribes of the
great plains it could have been done
with the hand a weapon or a whip but it
was most commonly done with a coup stick
a long peeled wand with a feather on the
end the challenge was getting close
enough to the enemy to touch him and
then escape without getting injured or
killed it was generally seen as more
honorable than killing or scalping the
enemy but at the same time it was a
great humiliation for the target so most
native warriors would have gone to great
lengths to avoid being the ones that
someone else counted kuan anyway when he
was 14 jumping badger was presented with
a coup stick and joined a lakota war
party on a raid against the crow who
were their greatest enemy at the time
during the fight the young man was
successful in counting coup against a
crow warrior this filled his father with
pride and when they returned home the
tribe had a ceremony to honor the young
warrior and mark his passage into
adulthood he also received a new name
that was more worthy of him and jumping
badger became sitting bull
[Music]
at 14 sitting ball was already regarded
as a warrior and he continued his
meteoric rise through the ranks of the
lakota tribe he was a member of several
groups most notably of the strong heart
society which was made up of the bravest
and most elite warriors he was then
given the prestigious title of sash
wearer and became the leader of the
group in 1856. sitting ball proved
himself to be a natural leader and it
was only fitting that he became one of
the people who shaped their tribe's
relationships with the outside world
particularly after his father was killed
in a fight with a crow warrior at first
he was indifferent to the u.s government
and white settlers he said i have seen
nothing that the white man has which is
as good as our right to roam and live on
the open plains as we choose that being
said he wasn't hostile either growing up
most of the interactions with white
people that he experienced were positive
since most of them involved fur traders
who were eager to stay on friendly terms
with the lakota but as settlers and
prospectors kept expanding westward
animosity developed on both sides that
inevitably turned violent this resulted
in the dakota war of 1862 also known by
many other names such as the sioux
uprising or little crows war the
conflict started in minnesota which had
only become a state a few years earlier
to help colonize the territory the u.s
government passed the homestead act in
1862 which promised 160 acres of land to
any person or family who claimed that
land and then lived and cultivated it
for five years most of that territory
originally belonged to native american
groups such as the dakota and ojibwe
people on paper the american government
obtained all the land fair and square by
either buying it directly or setting up
reservations where the native tribes
were supposed to receive regular
payments and supply shipments but the
government regularly broke the treaties
which were heavily in their favor to
begin with payments were missed supplies
were late and contracts were
renegotiated to get more and more
concessions by 1858 the dakota people
from minnesota lived on a small strip of
land and many of them were starving due
to the lack of food shipments and their
inability to hunt frustration turned to
anger which turned to violence in 1862 a
faction of dakota warriors led by chief
little crow began raiding settlements
and stores launching a six-week long war
that saw the deaths of over 350 settlers
the civil war slowed down the government
response but the dakota eventually
fought an army consisting mainly of
volunteers they were decisively defeated
at the battle of wood lake and
littlecrow was later killed during a
raiding party afterwards dozens of
dakota warriors were hanged for their
role in the war and the government
voided all treaties with the dakota
people forcing them to leave minnesota
altogether
[Music]
sitting bull had no role in this war but
his people and many other tribes
suffered the consequences all the same
as the government decided to punish all
the sioux by sending military
expeditions into their territory to push
them back even further it was in june
1863 that sitting bull first fought the
united states army but this was just a
minor skirmish a real fight occurred a
year later on july 28 1864 at the battle
of kildare mountain this conflict
involved around 4 000 soldiers in total
which may have been the largest single
battle between the u.s army and the
plains tribes larger than the more
famous battle of little bighorn that
we'll cover in a bit on one side there
were two brigades led by brigadier
general alfred sully around 2200
soldiers their mission usually referred
to as sully's expedition was to weaken
the sioux however possible and get them
to relocate further west best way to do
this was to destroy their villages they
had already done it once back at white
stone hill back in september 1863 and
now they had their sights set on a new
target an even larger sioux encampment
near the little missouri river in
present-day dunn county north dakota on
the other side were around 1 600
warriors most of them belonging to
various lakota tribes sitting bull was
there as the leader of the papa
alongside another famed warrior named
gaul sally was expecting an enemy force
double even triple what he actually
encountered but he had superior
firepower which also included two
cannons the fight was fairly one-sided
that lakota tried a few times to charge
into the ranks of the army soldiers but
their guns kept the warriors at bay
until they finally reached within cannon
range once that happened the battle was
pretty much over sully batted the
village with cannon fire until the
inhabitants had no choice but to abandon
it the following day his men marched
into the settlement and destroyed
everything including food and supplies
so that the lakota would have no reason
to return for many warriors like sitting
bull it was the first time that they
encountered artillery in battle and were
finally realizing the strength that they
were up against even so they did not
retreat completely and instead kept
harassing sully's troops with small
raids as the army made its way through
the rugged hills and the steep ravines
west of kildare mountain this eventually
culminated in the battle of the badlands
almost two weeks after their first
conflict once again superior firepower
won the day and sully ended his military
campaign once the lakota had been driven
into montana during this time sitting
bull was hardly the only lakota leader
who fought the united states army in
1866 another violent conflict emerged
known as red cloud's war which was led
by chief red clown leader of the oglala
lakota people for two years he fought
the u.s army for control of the powder
river country region in wyoming strictly
speaking when a treaty had been signed
that land belonged to the crow people
however the oglala fought them over it
the same way that they had done for
centuries and they won so they
considered the territory rightfully
theirs then the u.s government tried
taking advantage of the situation to
drive them away since that was an
important piece of land that territory
contained part of the bozeman trail
which at that time was the shortest
route that took settlers and prospectors
from the oregon trail in wyoming to the
gold rush region of montana it was a
route that the government desperately
wanted to control so they tried building
several new forts to gain a foothold in
the area what made this conflict notable
was that it ended in a victory for the
lakota for most of the war red cloud and
his allies which included sitting bull
resorted to raids and other blitz
attacks that being said there were a few
large-scale battles such as the
fetterman fight which ended in decisive
victories for the dakota eventually the
u.s government sought peace and signed
the treaty of fort laramie in 1868 the
military agreed to abandon the forts and
retreat from the area more importantly
the treaty established the gracie
reservation a large swath of land that
was reserved for native people it also
recognized the black hills in the dakota
territory as being unseated territory
that was sacred to the lakota as their
place of origin and granted them
exclusive use of it around 130 tribal
leaders signed the treaty of fort
laramie but sitting bull was not one of
them he didn't do it because he didn't
want to move his people or change their
way of life but his actions proved
somewhat prophetic because it took the
united states government less than a
decade to break the treaty once they
discovered that there was gold in those
hills
throughout the late 1860s and early
1870s sitting bull continued to carry
out minor skirmishes against various
parties that entered lakota territory
most notable of all being a group
working for the northern pacific railway
who wanted to lay down track over land
which sitting bull considered to belong
to the hong papa some sources claim that
during this time sitting bull became the
supreme chief of sioux nation but others
strongly contend that no such position
existed at most sitting bull came to be
regarded as the unofficial leader of the
non-treaty lakota meaning all the native
americans who refused to sign and adhere
to the treaty of fort laramie and lived
outside the great sioux reservation in
1874 the united states government
dispatched the seventh cavalry to the
black hills inside the dakota territory
their mission was to scout for a
suitable location for a new fort but
also to search the area for natural
resources specifically they were to
investigate a rumor that there might be
gold in the black hills this was a time
when america was firmly gripped with
gold fever the california gold rush had
a massive effect on the country's
economy and its migration toward the
west so the possibility of a similar
scenario in dakota was just too good to
ignore therefore on july the 2nd 1874 a
thousand soldiers and 110 wagons set off
on the black hills expedition led by
lieutenant colonel george armstrong
custer the california gold rush also had
a devastating effect on the native
american population and in august 1874
the worst thing possible for them
happened custer found gold in the black
hills he described as an extensive area
rich in gold deposit and in just a week
the new york tribune proclaimed the
black hills to be new gold country
nowhere in custer's report or the
newspapers was it mentioned that the
land was the gold was legally the
lakotas by autumn over 15 000 miners
have already made their way to the
dakota territory at first the army was
there to arrest and evacuate the
prospectors who snuck into lakota land
although it was mainly saving them from
being killed by the native americans the
government made an offer of six million
dollars to purchase the black hills an
offer which was firmly rejected by
sitting bull at that point president
ulysses s grant pretty much said screwed
the treaty and pulled the army from the
region allowing people to travel
unimpeded to the black hills in december
1875 grant gave a deadline of january 31
1876 by which point all the sioux people
had to relocate inside the great sioux
reservation those who failed to do so
would be considered and treated as
hostiles even if sitting bull would have
been willing to move which he wasn't it
would have been almost impossible to do
it in such a short time and during the
middle of winter therefore he saw no
other choice the deadline passed and the
great sioux war began
word of sitting bull's refusal to accept
any kind of deal with the american
government reached other tribes that
were living outside the great zoo
reservation the first half of 1876 or
many of them make their way to sitting
bull's camp which soon turned into a
village with around 10 000 people on the
bank of the little bighorn river these
were mainly lakota and dakota sioux but
also some northern cheyenne and arapaho
the exact number of warriors remains
disputed to this day but it's generally
estimated to be around 2 000 and besides
sitting bull other prominent leaders
included garl and the famed warrior
crazy horse the opening skirmish of the
conflict which was also known as the
black hills war occurred in may 1876
when six cavalry troops led by colonel
joseph j reynolds attacked a native
american village in montana's powder
river valley reynolds split his army
into four groups but due to a
miscalculation from the colonel only one
reached the village in time although
they managed to destroy the village they
also sustained casualties and ultimately
were forced to retreat for his actions
reynolds was later charged with
dereliction of duty and court-martialed
another notable fight was the battle of
rosebud on june 17 named after montana's
rosebud creek this was a bigger affair
that included around a thousand soldiers
on each side but like the first one
sitting bull was not involved rather
this one saw general george crook go
against crazy horse and his oglala
lakota warriors crook also had
assistance from the crow and the
shoshone who had allied themselves with
the u.s government in this war but he
still narrowly avoided a bloody crushing
defeat that would have seen most of his
troops wiped out technically he won the
battle because he had control of the
battlefield when it was said and done
but this is usually regarded as a
strategic victory for the sioux and the
cheyenne they inflicted a lot of damage
and they retreated from the battlefield
of their own accord emboldened by their
success against the american army but
most importantly they completely
immobilized crooks unit left with little
supplies and plenty of wounded crook
soldiers would play no part in the
bigger battle that was about to take
place just a days later came the famed
battle of little bighorn known as the
battle of the greasy grass to the dakota
originally the army planned a
three-pronged approach involving three
military columns coming from different
directions that would have culminated in
one big attack against sitting bull's
village one of those three columns was
the one led by general crook and that
one had been eliminated by crazy horse
another one was led by colonel john
gibbon who had been delayed and was not
in the area at the time of the battle
that left the third column by general
alfred terry on june 22nd terry sent a
scouting party ahead which consisted of
the same seventh cavalry regiment that
first discovered gold in the black hills
once again commanded by lieutenant
colonel george armstrong custer on the
morning of june 25th custer found
sitting bull's camp and in a very
fool-hearty move decided not to wait for
reinforcements he had between 600 and
700 soldiers with him and he thought
that would be enough to defeat the
lakota even though he was uncertain of
how many warriors awaited him of course
the lakota had their own scout since
sitting bull was aware of the impending
attack and was ready to strike back we
should mention that although sitting
bull is generally the native american
closest associated with this battle many
sources claim that he didn't actually
fight by this point he would have been
in his mid to late 40s so his role was
more of a spiritual leader whereas the
young braves were led in battle by crazy
horse and gall it was around
mid-afternoon that custard decided to
launch his attack and almost immediately
it became clear that he'd made a big
mistake his 700 cavalry men were up
against a force numbering in the
thousands and they were quickly
overwhelmed after just 20 minutes of
fighting the lakota had already gained
the upper hand and had forced the u.s
soldiers to fall back kustra divided his
army into five groups and although they
all sustained heavy losses the brunt end
was felt by the detachment led by kuster
himself they retreated to higher ground
where they were surrounded by their
enemies and killed the very last man
this final resistance became known as
custer's last stand and the place where
it happened is now a memorial called
lost stand hill the battle had been a
disaster for the us army as it gave it
its worst defeat in all of its many wars
against the sioux however looking back
at it it can also be regarded as the
beginning of the end for the dakota for
starters they had to go on the march
immediately since they knew that a
stronger army would have followed but
this also forced the government to
increase its efforts against the zoo
dramatically besides bringing in
thousands of extra soldiers it also
applied great pressure on the native
tribes within the reservation to meet
the non-treaty leaders and convince them
to surrender even cutting off their
rations until they succeeded chief red
cloud was the one who led this
delegation and he convinced many of the
people led by crazy horse to surrender
on may 5 1877.
once again sitting ball had no interest
in a treaty with the government so when
the others surrendered he took his group
of a few hundred hunk papa lakota across
the northern border but life in canada
proved very difficult the winters were
cold and the buffalo were scarce more
and more people were leaving sitting
bull's tribe and returning to the
reservation ultimately after four years
of harsh living the lakota leader
omitted defeat in 1881 he returned to
the united states and surrendered to the
american government at first sitting
bull was placed under arrest and sent to
stay in an army fort but in 1883 he was
released and allowed to live on the
standing rock reservation there he still
resisted change particularly in his
refusal to learn how to farm to the
annoyance of agents in charge of the
reservation sitting bull discovered that
he didn't need to learn in order to
survive following the battle of little
bighorn the lakota chief had become
quite notorious in the country and
people were eager to meet him he began
charging for photographs and autographs
and was able to live off his newfound
fame in 1884 sitting ball met annie
oakley the performing sharpshooter and
the two struck up a friendship as the
lakota leader was greatly impressed with
her shooting skills he even gave her the
nickname little shoreshot a moniker she
adopted and began using in a stage act
soon afterwards sitting bull met another
notable figure of that era buffalo bill
cody the man who brought the wild west
experience to people all over the
country and even in europe with his
touring show he convinced sitting ball
to join him a move that made the former
warrior even more famous it was pretty
easy living sitting bull made 50 a week
plus another 1 per autograph and all he
had to do was ride around in a circle
and talk even so he only lasted for 4
months before it decided to return to
the reservation even though sitting bull
no longer had any official authority he
was still revered by the lakota
something the reservation agents greatly
resented in the late 1880s a paiute
religious leader named oavoka began
travelling from tribe to tribe and
prophesizing a resurgence of the native
people something which became known as
the ghost dance movement this worried
the government because they feared that
it might cause the native americans to
rise up again and begin a new war they
were particularly concerned about the
ghost dance movement gaining support
from prominent leaders and at the time
there was no living leader greater than
sitting bull on december 15 1890
reservation agent james mclaughlin sent
indian police to arrest sitting bull
they burst into his cabin early in the
morning and took him outside despite
being close to 60 years old the former
warrior was as stubborn and defiant as
ever and refused to cooperate in a short
while the police were surrounded by
angry lakota men with guns and rifles
one of them took the first shot and in
retaliation the indian police opened
fire on sitting bull shooting him in the
head and the chest killing him almost
instantly another dozen men also died in
the gunfight that ensued as for the
ghost dance movement the government took
care of it just two weeks later when it
orchestrated the wounded knee massacre
killing between 150 and 250 lakota
people many of them women and children
to show that it was prepared to crush
even the slightest into rebellion caused
by anger over the murder of sitting bull
so i really hope you enjoyed this video
thank you again to conflict of nations
for sponsoring remember if you want to
jump into their grand strategy game use
the link in the description below to
start playing and that'll get you the
bonus 13 000 gold in a month for free
premium it's a very cool deal and as
always
thank you for watching